ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ก็กลับมาพบกับเราสองคนอีกแล้ว
โอเคนั่นแหละแกน่าจะแกงไม่ใช่ไม่ไม่ได้
ให้มาร้องเพลง
หนู
ร้องเพลงให้นักเรียนฟังกับพบกับสุภารักษ์
ผู้หญิงดีใครหานักเรียนน่ะอยากฟังครูฟ้า
ร้องเพลงไหม
เอเออยากฟัง
บีอยากฟังมากๆก็ไม่ได้ใช่ไม่รู้เหมือนกัน
เอเชียอยากฟังบีไม่อยากฟังนักเรียนจะมี
เพื่อนๆ
ก็เห็นเลือกได้ไหม
เอยากฟังบีไม่อยากฟังได้บอกว่ามีสิ
ลลี่บีชเฮ้าส์นักเรียนไม่ลังเลเลยเหรอ
เรื่องแบบไม่ลังเลเลยไม่คิดก่อน
AB
AB ไม่ต้องคิดเลยนักเรียนเลือกได้เลยว่า
บีไม่อยากฟัง
เกณฑ์ Under เกณฑ์อันนั้นเองเขาเลือก B
ค่ะเมาอยากฟัง
อยากร้อง
เรียนไม่อยากฟังโอเคแต่กูฟ้าอยากร้องเพลง
โอ้ยวิ่งพูดอะไรผู้หญิงกันเลยค้าบอกว่า
นักเรียนเลือดเลือกไม่อยากฟังใช่ไหมนัก
เรียนเลือกดีคุณอยู่แล้วนั่งเรียนเรื่อง
ถ้าไม่ลังเลเลยหรอ
ว่างแล้วไอซ์ไม่เห็นเข้าใจเลยเอ้าลังเลก็
คือแบบเลือกไม่ได้ไงเลือกไม่ได้แบบไม่
อยากฟังมั้ยแต่ถ้าบอกว่าไม่อยากฟังครูฟ้า
ก็เสียใจแต่เราก็ไม่ได้อยากฟังแต่ถ้า
เลือกไม่อยากฟังครูฟ้าอาจจะไม่โอเคใช่นัก
เรียนก็ลังเลไงเองหรือบี 1 ตัวเองหรือ B
ใช่มั้ยยังไงวะลังเลเรื่องเล่ห์คือเรา
เลือกไม่ได้หรอ
อ๋อ
อย่างนี้ให้หนูยังไงครูฟ้าเนี่ยพ่อชอบกิน
ไก่ทอด
แน่นอนค่ะพอชอบกินไก่ทอดเมืองมา
ก่อนโหมดหมูทอดกลิ่น
มีการซ่อน
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยครูฟ้าไม่ต้องเลือกใช่ไหม
ว่าประเทศไทยก็จะมีร้านไก่ทอดก็คือ KFC  1
ล้านถูกต้องซึ่งดิฉันอย่างร้าน sign  in
ทุกตอนนี้ไม่ใช่ไงตอนนี้มันมีร้านไก่ทอด
กับใหญ่ๆแล้วกันเนาะพี่ซื้อง่ายๆมีทุกที่
อยู่ 2 ร้านใช่ไหมถ้าคุณหญิงบอกว่ากูฟ้า
ไปกินข้าวไหมวันนี้ครูหญิงจ่ายเงินฟรี
กุมภากินครีมหรอช้ายไปกินไก่ทอดไก่ทอด
ไก่ทอดฟรีตายแต่ว่าครูไม่ลังเล
ไปกับไม่ไปใช่ไหมปลายไม่ไปไปสิหิงค์แต่
ไปแน่นอน 4Shared ลังเลว่าคุยถามว่าไปไหม
อินทรีย์ไหมกินฟรีฟรีอะไร
กินไม่ลังเล
แต่ครูฟ้าต้องเลือกมันมีร้านไก่ทอด 2
ร้าน
ไก่ทอดส่งร้านหรออะไรอ่ะอร่อยเอง
ae1  k  f  4
ร้านที่สองชิกชิกเท็กซัสชิคเก้น
โว้
KFC ก็อร่อยใช่ไหมเท็กซัสชิกเก้นก็อร่อย
ครูฟ้าอยากจะไปกินร้านไหนกูว่าต้องเลือก
AB
ปุ้ยฟันเลือดต้องเรื่องนั้นสองทางร้านไม่
ได้
KFC เนี่ยเป็นไก่ทอด
Texas  Chicken ก็เป็นไก่ทอด
KFC ก็เอาข่อย 1 คลิกกินก็อร่อย
อะไรอ่ะ
ว่าคิดก่อน
AB  AB
2 ล้านเลยได้ไหม A แล้ว
เรื่องหนึ่งล้านเลือกแล้วเปลี่ยนไม่ได้นะ
ไม่ใช่บอกว่าเออ KFC แล้วก็เดินผ่านแบบ
ต้องใช้ซะทีขึ้นก็หอมแล้วก็ Texas
Chicken แล้วก็ KFC  The กำลังเลวๆๆ
เลือกต้องเลือกหนึ่งเลือกไม่ได้คุยอึ๋ง
ท่าเรือ vs  KFC ก็ไก่ทอดอร่อย Texas
Chicken ก็ไก่ทอดชิ้นใหญ่
KFC ก็เป๊ปซี่รีฟิล Texas  Chicken ก็
ไม่แพงเรื่องไม่ได้เนี่ยหลังเล่ห์ว่างนี้
ขอโอ้โหถ้าแบบนี้กูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นคนลังเล
หรอใช่อ้ะมันเป็นหรอวะยังไง
มากคือคู่ฟ้าจะเลือกอะไรไม่ได้เลย
เดี๋ยววันเนี้ยใส่เสื้อใช่ไหมค่ะเพื่อน
แดงกับเสื้อสีฟ้า
ฟ้ายืนคิดอยู่นานมาก
เปิดสู้หรอเกิดตู้แล้วก็ดูเสื้อเสื้อสี
แดง
หรือว่าเสื้อน้องหมาสีฟ้าสีน้ำเงิน
เสื้อสีฟ้ายิงออกมาใช่ไหมค่ะแดงสีฟ้า
ใส่เจ้าไหนดีจะใส่สีอะไรดี
อีสีอะไรดี
เลือกไม่ได้
รักนี
ลังเลผู้หญิงฝรั่งเลย์มาเป็นคนขี้ลังเล
หรอคะให้หาบอกเป็นคนขี้ลังเล
หือก็คือเป็น
เลือกไม่ได้ทุกเรื่องๆเลือกไม่ได้เลย
ว่าจะเป็นอาหารใช่ไหมโอ้โหเรื่องที่ลังเล
มาก
มากก็คืออาหารน่ะโครง
คิดว่าคุณน่าจะคะนักเรียนก็มีและลังเล
อาหารเนี่ย
อะไรใช่ไหมให้ผู้หญิงจะแบบถ้ากูฟ้าอยู่
กับเพื่อนใช่ไหมค่ะอยู่กับพฤติมีแกงมี
แจ้งขึ้นเพื่อนๆเพื่อนๆเพื่อนๆเพื่อนๆ
เพื่อนๆก็จะถามว่าป๊าวันนี้กินอะไร
มาฝากก็จะคิดใช่ไหมเดินดูแล้วก็คิดกุ้ย
ร้านนี้ก็อร่อยและนี้ไก่อร่อยอุ้ยร้านนี้
หรืออร่อยร้านทิศปูอร่อย
รึตาย
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวก็อยากกินพิซซ่าก็น่าอร่อยไม่
ไก่ทอดก็อร่อยมากๆ
อะไรดีอ้ะหลัง
มีหมึกเลยเลือกไม่ได้ใช่ไหมทรายรักหานะ
คือเวลากินอ่ะกินอะไรใช่มั้ยกินอะไรเนี่ย
ว่าคิดว่าทุกคนก็น่าจะเป็นไม่รู้กินอะไร
ลังเล
จ่ายอันนี้ก็น่ากินอันนี้ก็น่ากินอันนี้
ก็น่ากิน
ก็เลยต้องมี
แอพพลิเคชั่นเนาะ
ไอ้แอพพลิเคชั่น Grab เนี่ยนะคะที่เวลา
เราสั่งอาหารอ่ะบางครั้งอ่ะเราเรื่องนาน
มากเพราะเราเลือกไม่ได้ใช่ไหมเราลังเลเรา
เลือกอยู่อ่ะบางครั้งมันก็ขึ้นมาว่ายัง
เลือกไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
ฉันให้
เขาหากูว่าเราเนี่ยลังเล
ให้เนี่ยนักเรียนดูกินอะไรดีใช่มะ
Mcdonald ก็อยากกินพิซซ่า
ไปกิน
ซีฟู๊ดก็อยากกินใช่มั้ย kf อย่างเงี้ยเอา
ปวดหัวเลย
ดูแอปโดนแฮกเลือกใครแล้ว Application ไม่
รักเล็บ
มันเป็นปล่อยมากเค้าจะบอกว่าคนที่ลังเล
เนี่ยถ้าขับรถใช่ไหมถ้าขับรถมันจะไม่โอเค
นะเอาจริงหรอเวลาถอนขับรถอ่ะเวลาจะเลี้ยว
ไงมันก็ต้องเลี้ยวถ้าแบบเลี้ยวไม่เลี้ยง
เลี้ยวไม่เลี้ยวไม่ได้มีรถข้างหลังไง
จะไปไหนจะเลี้ยวหรือว่าจะตรง
หลักนี้เวลาขับรถกินอาหารโอเค
กูมาเนี่ยขับรถ
ไม่เป็นอะ
และก็เลยโอเคใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าเขาเลยถ้า
เกิดครูฟ้าขับรถได้ขับรถโอเคน่ะกูฟ้าต้อง
ลังเลแน่ๆเลย
ไปทางไหนดีตรงมั้ยยกสารหายไม่โอเคเลย
ตรงไหน
คือขวาเนี่ยเป็นคนลังเล
เยอะมากๆคือก็มาเนี่ยบอกว่าครูฟ้าเป็นคน
ลังเลมากๆจนเราเรียกว่าขี้ลังเล
ใช่มั้ยลังเลยดีๆใช่เพราะว่าในภาษาไทย
เนี่ยเวลาที่เราเป็นอะไรมากๆมันจะมีคำว่า
ขี้อยู่ข้างหน้าไม่ใช่กูอยู่ว่าคุณเป็นคน
ลังเลกะธรรมดา
จะครูฟ้าเดี๋ยวกูเขาบอกว่าลังเลมากๆทุก
เรื่องเลือกไม่ได้
ฟ้าเป็นคนขี้ลังเลหรอก็คือมากๆดูหนังใช่
หางจริงเพราะว่าพละเนี่ยทำไมถึงลังเลใช่
ไหมจ่ายทำไมคะมันมีหามีหรอวะ
เป็นหรอหลายยีสั้นเลย wasun ฮะเพราะมี
หลายอยู่เขตโทษมา
มองอะไรคุณลังเลอยู่แล้วเขาก็คือจะพูด
อะไร
กำลังวาดลูกให้นักเรียนดูอยู่ว่าไม่เข้า
ใจว่าทำไมครูฟ้าวไม่มองฟ้าวาดรูปลูกอัน
นี้ครูฟ้านะคะค่ะไม่ลังเลหรออันนี้กว่า
ได้นอนอันนี้คุณแม่
อันนี้คือพ่อใช่ไหมค่ะทำไม M ตัวเล็กและ
ดีตัวใหญ่เดียว
ทำไมอ่ะเกี่ยวอะไรกับคุณพ่อคุณแม่กูฟ้า
กูฟ้าเนี่ยตั้งแต่กูฟ้าเกิดมาใช่ไหมอ่ะอา
ยุ
1-25 เนี่ยค่ะ
ก็คือ
คุณแม่จะเป็นอน์ชิดเลือกให้ครูบายอ่ะอ๋อ
ครูฟ้าไม่เคยเรื่องเองเลย
ให้อย่างวันนี้ใส่เสื้ออะไรเด็กๆน้องฟ้า
เด็กๆอายุ
อายุสิบขวบ
แหวนอายุสิบขวบคุณแม่ก็จะอ้าวฟ้าฟ้า
ใส่เสื้อสีแดงโอเค
เรือมาใช่ไหมฟ้าใส่กางเกงเนาะเวลาเดินใส่
กางเกงอันนี้โอเคในก็จะหยิบฝาสลึงไม่ได้
คิดช่วยหาคุณแม่มีเสื้อให้มีกางเกงให้
มันก็เลยโอเคใส่อันนี้แล้วก็ลงมาอ่ะหน้า
ม้ากินอะไร
แม่ก็จะไรคิดให้ให้วันนี้ฟ้ากิน
สปาเก็ตตี้เนาะเดี๋ยวแม่ก็ไปทำสมัครเน็ต
ตี้มาให้กูป่ามากเลยโอเคสปาเก็ตตี้ก็โอเค
ไม่ต้องคิดนะ
สบายมั้ยไม่คิดอะไรเลยไม่คิดไม่คิด
แม่คิดให้แง่คิดให้ด้วยนะค่ะ
ก็เลยไม่ได้คิดอะไรตั้งแต่เด็กๆจนหูฟ้า
อายุ 25
แม่อายุไทยอยู่ไหมต้องคิดเองอ่ะก็คิดเอง
เลยอ่ะอ่าอ๋อ
มันก็เลยจะลังเลเราก็เลยกลายเป็นคนเลือก
ไม่ได้
เด็กสมัยตั้งแต่เด็กๆไม่เคยเลือกมีอยู่
แล้ว
เออเหมือนกระดาษทิชชู่เนี่ยเฮ้
คุณเลือกไม่ได้เหรอคะว่าจะใช้อันไหนก็เลย
ซื้อทั้งสองถูกต้องค่ะเลือกไม่ได้ว่าจะ
เอากระดาษทิชชูแบบนี้ดีไหมแบบเป็นแผ่นยาว
ใช่ไหมกับกระดาษทิชชูแบบม้วนคว้าไปอยู่
ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตก็ยืนคิด
อะไรดีเรื่องอันไหนดีนะ
อันไหนดีกว่ากัน
ม้วนเดชเปลี่ยนแผน
หมดเลยไม่ได้
ทั้งหมดก็เลยเนี่ยเกิดทิชชูนะคะก็เลยทั้ง
สองอย่างดีนะที่วันนี้คุณเลือกไม่ได้ว่า
เสื้อสีแดงหรือว่าเซื่องเงินแล้วคุณไม่
ใส่น่ะ 2 ตัว
เพื่อให้เด็กเอาเงินด้วยไม่ฮาอ่ะอีกรอบ
เหมือนประการเหมือนกันเนี่ย
ไปช้อปปิ้งไปซื้อปากกา
ก็เข้าไปยืนคิดว่าเราต้องใช้ปากกาสีอะไร
น้ำเงิน
ดำแดงนะน้ำเงินดำแดงสีอะไร
เรื่องไม่ได้คะลังเลก็เอามากด
ซื้อทั้งหมดอ๋อ
คุยสีแดงรู้แล้วว่า
ถ้าผู้หญิงจะชวนครูฟ้าไปเที่ยวไหนสมมุติ
มี Happy  New  Year ลองวีคเอนแล้วก็จะไป
เที่ยวมีเวลาผู้หญิงก็จะบอกต้องผู้หญิงจะ
ไม่มีถอยให้กูฟ้าเลือกเจ๊มีกุ้งฟ้าครูฟ้า
จะไปเชียงใหม่หรือว่าจะไปภูเก็ตหญิงจะไม่
ถามคุณก็จะวะครูฟ้าไปเชียงใหม่เนาะ
เพราะโอเคว่า
มันจะได้ซื้อตั๋วได้ถ้าคุย 6 คู่ฟ้าจะไป
เชียงใหม่หรือว่าไปภูเก็ตดีอ่ะ
เชียงใหม่หรือว่าภูเก็ตภูเก็ตหรือว่า
เชียงใหม่
กูฟ้าเรื่องอะไรเชียงใหม่คือเก็บแป๊บ
เชียงใหม่ก็คน
คุยแล้วเนี่ยตอนนี้โปรโมชั่นเนี่ย
โปรโมชั่นมันจะหมดแล้วมีเวลา 10 นาที
เชียงใหม่ภูเก็ต
ซื้อ 2 เลยเชียงใหม่ภูเก็ตด้วยเดี๋ยวให้
คนดีเวลา 5 วัน
เชียงใหม่ 3 วันภูเก็ต 2 วันนี้หรอไม่ไป
ทั้งหมดไปทั้งหมด
ไม่ได้ต้องเลือกเลือกชนะว่าได้เป็นคน
ลังเลว่างคือไม่ว่าจะอะไรในบ้านต้องมีสอง
นะคะก็คือถ้าเลือกไม่ได้ให้อันนี้อะไรคะ
นี่คืออันนี้คืออัลบั้มเพลงคุยกับคริสต์
แม้เป็นอัลบั้มเป็นอัลบั้มเนาะนักร้องที่
อุบายชอบ
เหมือนกันแต่มี 2 สีเห็นไหมสีฟ้ากับ
สี Deep ส้มสี Piece  Complete  his สี
พีช
อยู่เลือกนานมาก
ลังเลแล้วเอาสีอะไรดีอ่ะแต่ว่าข้างใน
เนี่ยเหมือนกันนะเหมือน recent เลยใช่ไหม
ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นเหมือนกันค่ะมีแค่สีใช่ไหม
สีฟ้ากับสีพีชที่ไม่เหมือนฟ้ายืนเลือกนาน
มากลังเลเลือกไม่ได้ก็เลยซื้อมาสองอันขอ
ฮะโอเคคนซื้อด้วย
คนอย่างกูไฟล์ฮะซื้อ
2 อย่างทุกอย่างก็มีสองเพราะว่าลังเล
จ่ายเพราะว่าเลือกไม่ได้ไงเออเรื่องไม่
ได้ว่าจะเอาอันนี้ดีหรือว่าอันนี้ดียังไง
เราก็จะบอกว่าลังเล
ลังเลไข่เนาะตายแต่ว่านักเรียนไม่ต้อง
เลือกไงไม่ต้องเลือกครูฟ้าหรือว่าครูหญิง
ใช่ไหมโทรมาทั้ง 2
ผู้หญิงมาด้วยกันสองคนนั้น
ในต้องเรียนไม่ต้องเลือกค่ะเราก็ไม่ให้
เลือกให้กลัวนักเรียนไม่ลังเล
ให้กูนั่งเลือกแล้วก็
อย่าลืมมา Say  Okay นะคิด
นักเรียนไม่ลังเลกูไม่สบายใจนะคดีใจใช่
ตอนนี้เราสองคนก็คุยเรื่องลังเลใช่ไหมขา
หลังนั้นหรอก็หมดเวลาแล้วน้องก่อนไปนัก
เรียนก็ต้องชอบอะไรคะกดไลค์กดแชร์กด
Subscribe พี่ด้วยนะคะไปแล้วช่องคอร์ด
เพลงพี่เบิร์ดไทยโน้ตสีแดงๆสดไร้นะคะอย่า
ลังเลนะไม่ต้องลังเหล็กก็
เลยโอเคอ่าดีเราสองคนก็ก่อนแล้วเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้าบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
คุณค่าา